Kerner Alexander ovando Sanchez is on
the front line of the Colombian fight
against deforestation
he's in charge of operations in the
wavieri region in the Amazon rainforest
Sanchez says he's working with
prosecutors and specialized officers to
combat environmental crimes
we are looking at money launderers so we
can confiscate their property and they
repay the damage they are doing to the
Amazon his unit also controls all the
wood that lives the areas as well as
rescuing endangered species
after the government signed a peace
agreement with a left-wing Rebel group
The farc in 2016 millions of hectares of
land in this area were destroyed and
pristine forests were replaced with
cattle and grass to feed them the
government now is trying a different
approach and rather than Prosecuting
small farmers they're going after those
who finance deforestation
Colombia managed to reduce deforestation
by 30 percent in the past year
environment Minister Susana Muhammad
told Al Jazeera that combating the
illegal logging industry and working
with local communities are priorities
for Colombia's first left-wing President
we are not going to legalize land that
has been deforestated so that its price
increases and this is a clear message
that we have sent the other side is the
peasants the communities that have more
a culture of increasing the agricultural
Frontier but they are really low income
not very productive placing local
communities at the Forefront of the
fight against land grabs is also part of
the plan
is a community leader he has been
working with local ngos to reforest
areas close to a national park the
government has good intentions but there
are lots of people who want it to fail
who are part of the business and are in
Congress because they make the laws but
then they are the ones who do not
respect them the government has also the
task of protecting people like Rodriguez
as Colombia is one of the most dangerous
countries in the world for environmental
activists hundreds have been killed in
the last decade
Colombia's forests have also been a
victim of the war and the violence that
have plagued this country's history many
hope this time the political will will
be enough to revert the damage that has
already been done Colombia
and in the Bolivia
foreign